what's going on guys today we're talking
animation specifically celebrity cartoon
voices now we all know that Robin
Williams is the voice of the genie in
Aladdin and Jack Black is the big fat
Kung Fu Panda but there are a lot of
deeper cuts and we have a super special
guest to help us with this the universe
is for most cartoon expert his name is
Andre Meadows but you might know as
black nerd from YouTube's black nerd
comedy the cartoons begin so uh we both
have some lists of more obscure
celebrities who have voiced cartoons
yeah Eric ders let's kick it off yeah
what's one of the ones on your lip I hit
star on a sad note but this guy recently
passed away but James Avery who a lot of
us know as Uncle Phil from The Fresh
Prince of bel-air you know how
humiliating it is to have a son who
can't swim he was also the voice of the
shredder from the 1980s teenage Mutant
turtle series your hairy little friend
knows me as Oroku Saki but you may call
me the shredder what else I okay uh well
imma stick with my my sitcoms and wit
fresh prints the first time I'm gonna go
Family Matters
yeah everyone remembers Jaleel White
Arkel the original black nerd yeah the
original yeah my my mentor black nerd
dry
[Laughter]
[Music]
he was also the voice of a very popular
video game character he was the voice of
Sonic the Hedgehog take care of your
body and give it a regular safety check
cuz if it goes to pieces
so could you but I haven't seen any
YouTube mashups of that I think someone
needs to mash up Merkel quotes in Sonic
clips there's a call to action make it
make it happen I have a bit of a twofer
the Real Ghostbusters had the voices of
talk show host Arsenio Hall as Winston
cording to this the boogeyman lives on
kids fear the more scared they are the
better he likes it and then full House's
Dave Coulier but he was Venkman I just
remember I know deadly about computers
he was a replacement make them yeah cuz
originally it was Lorenzo music who was
also the voice of Garfield which then
Bill Murray voiced in the Garfield movie
right but I guess they kicked him out
and brought Dave Coulier in let's uh
let's have another one from well you
know you you probably a you probably
were a fan of the Reading Rainbow if you
want to find out more about pigs you
know where to go right
levar burton also the voice of Kwame
from Captain Planet and the Planeteers
Liga Queen uh you must call now
what's just wrong with you and then they
also had a guy who was like their guide
that was voiced by Whoopi Goldberg you
turned to Hope Island Planeteers
we have an eco emergency and then what
was weird about that cartoon was that
all the villains were guest voices so I
was like meg Ryan Jeff Goldblum I love
Jeff Goldblum what villain did he play
his name was like scrums eyes like this
like almost rat like creature Oh Captain
Planet get a little taste of this
[Music]
yeah here's another one where I go and
think about who this guy is now and I'm
like oh wow he did do that
Vin Diesel was the voice of the Iron
Giant it's weird to see him now you're
driving these cars ago that was that was
the Iron Giant right there give us
another one okay
well this is not a cartoon it's it but
it's in the same vein Bryan Cranston
would you have imagined him as a monster
that the Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
would fight the power of well he more
from a high school chemistry teacher you
a drug kingpin yeah exactly exactly
here's another one kind of obscured the
show didn't live long there have been a
number of Spider Man incarnations
cartoon wise but MTV had one in 2003 I
think kind of riding the coattails of
the first Tobey Maguire movie yeah and
the voice spider-man Neil Patrick Harris
maybe I need an image makeover I'm a
spider-man I loved him until he also did
the Smurfs movie oh yeah he's the main
guy in that worst movie Smurfs 2 or the
Squeakquel Justin Leung actually the
voice of Alvin in Wow equal and then the
Chipettes were uh Amy Poehler Christina
Applegate and I'm blanking on the third
one on Affairs Wow yeah like you just
pulled that out of nowhere ladies yeah
guys
what celebrity cartoon voices did we
leave off our list or do you have any
favorite ones that we didn't mention let
us know in the comments section below
the most fun answer we're going to send
you a screen junkies t-shirt I want to
thank my guest Andre Meadows a treasure
trove of cartoon knowledge sir um black
nerd comedy on YouTube and check them
out on Twitter at black nerd as Mike
on Twitter yeah there you go um I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter thanks for
watching guys bye bye guys if you want
to see more of this conversation and if
you want to see Andre just open up his
beautiful mind of cartoon nerd knowledge
click on the link that is somewhere on
this screen
[Music]